yeah changing over there it's a storm  comin re just say last time the ministry  of magic is pleased to announce the  appointment of Dolores Jane Umbridge as  high in visitor to address the falling  standards at Hogwarts School things are  hopeless a far worse than I feared  you have been told that a certain Dark  Wizard is at large this is a lie it's  not a lie I saw it  it's got to be able to defend ourselves  if I Madeira fuses to teach us how we  need somebody well every great wizard in  history who started out there's nothing  more than what we are now if they can do  it why not us certificates placing isn't  it superfine breaking rules who are you  and what have you done with the mind  games you're a really good teacher Harry  and ministers gonna have a full uprising  on their ass  it's your turn discipline your line  we're in this together  Voldemort building up  then I want to fight  Harry Potter you will lose everything  you